you've never heard of iCarly then
something's wrong with you you never
expected to become famous in your teens
but everything changed when Freddie
uploaded a video of you and Sam
auditioning for the school talent show
what Freddie did this behind your back
so you never saw it coming but Freddie
did you a solid because before you knew
it icarly became one of the most watched
web cast of all time yeah I guess it's
no secret that I'm a big fan of the
icarly web show
icarly ran from 2007 to 2012 and
throughout this time a lot of
celebrities guest-starred on the show
some of these actors would go on to
become pretty big deals in the industry
while others were already very
well-known keep watching to find out
which actor from Glee danced his way
into the cast Emma Stone in 2007 Emma
Stone starred as Jules in Superbad which
would later serve as her breakthrough
role she went on to star in movies like
the House Bunny eza
and Zombieland but in 2012 the a-list
actress agreed to guest star on iCarly
Emma appeared in the episode titled I
find Spencer friends in which she played
Heather a mega fan of the icarly web
cast Heather was totally starstruck to
say the least
Jim Parsons Jim Parsons is an
award-winning actor who made headlines
when he starred as Sheldon Cooper on the
Big Bang Theory Jim went on to become a
pretty big deal in Hollywood and
although many of his fans don't remember
this he played Caleb on iCarly
in 2011 Jim appeared in the episode
titled I lost my mind Jim played a
mental health hospital patient who
believed he was from the future I'm from
the Year 2077 Jack Black Jack Black is a
man who needs no introduction after all
he's been stealing the show since the
early 1990s in 2003 Jack Black and
miranda cosgrove both starred in the hit
movie School of Rock so it made total
sense that Jack would make a special
appearance on iCarly Jack portrayed the
character as far to me in the episode
titled I star of fan war as part timaya
was an overly committed world of
warlords player who dares interrupt this
epic battle a little too committed if
you ask us Harry Styles if there was one
boy band who ruled the
in 2012 it was one direction so icarly
fans totally lost it when the entire
group guest-starred as themselves on the
episode titled I go one direction in
this episode Harry takes a bad case of
the jungle worms
to get Carly's undivided attention wait
grab some more fruits but his plan goes
south when Carly catches him in the act
Chord Overstreet before landing the role
of Sam Evans on the hit TV series Glee
Chord Overstreet made waves on iCarly
he was the model turned singer who tried
to catch Carly's attention in the
episode titled I speed-date the cord
isn't the only Glee actor to have
appeared on the Nickelodeon series keep
watching to find out which Glee actor
also danced his way into the cast
Jordan Fisher Jordan Fischer played
holden dippledorf on Liv and Maddie and
would go on to be cast as John Ambrose
McLaren in the upcoming film to all the
boys PS I still love you but before he
became a well-known actor Jordan briefly
joined the cast of iCarly
Hart and pork nice to meet you Clark
just like Kourt Jordan had a small role
in the episode titled I speed-date Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy Fallon baby the man behind
the Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon
but the comedic actor has appeared in a
handful of productions like that time he
guest-starred as himself on iCarly would
you mind givin the audience a little
taste of that
in this episode Carly and the gang
encounter some legal troubles when they
get invited to be guests on Jimmy's talk
show Tina Fey comedian actress and
writer Tina Fey also appeared on iCarly
alongside Jimmy Fallon she made a small
cameo appearance as herself in season 6
episode 7 she was showcased trying to
help Jimmy turn off his webcam just
quick
having Tina Fey and Jimmy Fallon appear
on the same icarly episode was no small
feat Randall Park if you made it a point
to watch Netflix's always be my maybe
you'll recognize Randall Park in a flash
this comedian has appeared on big-time
productions like Ant Man and the wasp
and Aquaman but in 2008 Randall
portrayed mr. Palladino in the hilarious
episode I got detention Thank You
Freddie
Harry Shum Jr theory is well known for
playing Mike Chang on the musical TV
series Glee he's got some killer dance
moves and is known for being one of the
best dancers in the group but did you
know that back in 2008 Harry had a small
role on iCarly Harry portrayed Yuki in
the episode titled I go to Japan he
posed as a Japanese comedian who was
nominated for the same Internet Award as
Carly I call the for finish if you love
keeping up with your favorite movies and
TV shows subscribe to the things catch
up on the latest Disney Channel and
Nickelodeon news by clicking the bell
and enabling notifications if you're
watching on your phone go on YouTube
settings and turn on notifications so
you never miss another video and that's
a wrap on the 10th stars you forgot
we're on iCarly who was your favorite
character on the show and which couples
were you shipping tell us in the
comments before you go give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things we'll catch you next time
you